so then diplomatic sources in Sudan have
told Al Jazeera the Army is suspending
towards for the rapid support forces in
Saudi Arabia the two sides agreed a
five-day ceasefire extension on Monday
but it was violated a day later heavy
fighting took place across the capital
of Khartoum the deal was supposed to
allow the delivery of human humanitarian
Aid U.S and Saudi monitors say last
week's truce was subject to severe
violations uh let's come straight away
to others Muhammad Ali who's covered
Sudan extensively joins us here in the
studio so Mohammed tell us more about
this and what's happening
yeah Nick I think this is a culmination
of weeks of frustration on the part of
expressed frustration that part of the
Sudanese government and the military in
particular saying that
rsf continued to violate the ceasefires
and there is no meaning for this
ceasefire we still need to hear more
from the Army on this on this thing we
need an official statement which in
which they detail and probably reiterate
these reasons the reasons why they
withdrew from the talks we know that the
two sides limited themselves from the
very beginning to a humanitarian and a
humanitarian aspect to the negotiation
so it's not about ending the war and the
Army is more and more expressive and
vociferous about the the the the lack of
uh of of results and the the
yes the Vicious Cycle in which social
sites are you know every every ceasefire
has been violated this is I think the
the one that is going on now is the 13th
in weeks so every single ceasefire has
been invariably violated probably by the
two sides but they blame each other also
it depends it has to do with who has the
upper hand right now we have seen that
the chief of the rsf Muhammad hamdan the
glue is invisible it has been invisible
for weeks and rumors about his death on
the other hand we have al-burhan
increasing his visibility in the field
uh visiting his military in the field
and talking about what is next talking
about what the military should do in
case rsf refuses to comply to the
demands of the military either
surrendering surrendering or leaving
cartoon so even yesterday he talked
about the fact that the military hasn't
yet used enough force in this in this
battle to protect the lives of civilians
and if there is no change in the
behavior of the rsf the Army is going to
use lethal Force this time around right
you mentioned the humanitarian effort
tell us about that and how that is
affected by these continued violations
of the ceasefire because millions are in
need aren't they yeah you know the
purpose of the talks in Jeddah was to
stop the violations and to help the
civilians reorganize their life and you
know go to Safe places and so on but
that hasn't happened we still have
people fleeing cartoon we still have
people trapped in their homes in cartoon
because rsf and I mean according to the
reports is using civilians as human
Shields and also fighting inside the
residential areas so nothing has changed
actually and and that's why anybody in
the in Sudan any one of the two sides
can say that these truths truces and
these talks are good for nothing